- [Voiceover] Now that
we've read the passage,
let's see if we can answer
some questions around it.
So, question number one:
So, we remember that,
if I remember correctly,
the passage started with Adelita.
Adelita was his turtle,
and this 9,000-mile journey
was across the Pacific Ocean
from Mexico, from the West
coast of Mexico, to Japan,
so let's see what they're talking about.
Well, she couldn't have used
the North Atlantic gyre.
They do talk about that
later on in the passage
as ways that turtles in the Atlantic
navigate across the Atlantic,
but Adelita, though, what
the passage started with,
she was navigating across the Pacific,
so she's not gonna be using the current
of the North Atlantic gyre.
Well, they definitely talk
about electromagnetic coils
designed by Putman and
Lohmann in the passage,
and these researches used those coils
to test whether turtles
respond to it,
that it effects their sense of direction,
but Adelita didn't use the cues
from electromagnetic coils.
It's not like Putman and
Lohmann were on a boat
for 9,000 miles with,
kind of, electromagnetic
coils near Adelita
and using that to tell Adelita
how does she navigate
her 9,000 mile journey.
It's not like she had
access to these things.
She did it on her own.
Well, yeah, well that's what
the whole passage is about.
It kind of starts off with,
isn't it amazing that
this turtle can navigate
this 9,000 mile journey on its own
without some type of a GPS device.
And then it uses the research
of Putman and Lohmann
to show that turtles are able to do this
by using the inclination intensity
of Earth's magnetic field,
so that looks right.
Now, let's look at the last choice.
Well, once again, this is like choice B.
Adelita did not have access to technology
from the researcher or Lohmann,
so this is...
She was off by herself in the Pacific.
All right, number two.
So, once again, the answer
to the previous question
is that turtles use the
inclination and intensity
of Earth's magnetic field.
So, what's the best evidence
for us to feel good about that?
That turtles actually do use
the inclination and intensity
of Earth's magnetic field
to navigate across the Pacific,
or to navigate across an ocean.
Let's see, lines one through three.
So this is line one right over here.
They give us every fifth line.
Yeah, this is what they started off with.
It was an amazing statement.
This was kind of
starts to serve the problem to it.
Like, isn't this amazing?
But how does this happen?
But this doesn't give evidence or explain
why or how they use the
inclination and intensity
so let me scroll back.
That doesn't give evidence
that they use the inclination
and intensity of Earth's magnetic field,
so I'm gonna cross that one out.
Let's see, lines 30 to 32.
Well, we later do use this,
you know, Lohmann uses this technology
that he's developed
to test whether turtles respond
but this sentence by itself
isn't providing evidence.
It's just starting to say that hey Lohmann
can mimic magnetic
fields at different parts
of the Earth's surface,
so I don't think that this is...
I don't think this is evidence either.
I'm sorry, I have to
kind of keep scrolling
back and forth like this.
Let's see,
53 to 55.
So, let's see, that's
this right over here.
Well, if we remember,
this is when they said,
"Look,
"the turtles use the magnetic field
"and they might also
use this other stuff."
"You know, the stars, the
position of the sea, sun and stars
"might also help them," but
once again this isn't evidence
for us believing that they
use Earth's magnetic field.
These are just other
things that they might use.
So, let me just cross that one out.
So, deductive reasoning,
it's probably gonna be D,
but let's check it out.
Line 64,
64 to 67, starting with, "Neither,"
so that's right near the end.
And when they're saying, "neither,"
they're talking about
different parts of the world
have unique combinations
of these two variables,
and those two variables are the intensity,
the intensity of the magnetic field,
and the angle of the magnetic field,
so neither corresponds directly to either
latitude or longitude.
And when they're saying, "neither,"
they're saying neither the
intensity or the angle.
But together, they provide
a magnetic signature
that tells the turtle where it is.
So, this is the closest that I would say
to actually providing evidence
that turtles, that the angle and intensity
of a magnetic field can
provide a signature to turtles
to tell them where they are.
So I like that one.
It's actually the best of all of these,
so I would go with D.
All right, let's check out line three.
Used in line three.
So, he put a tag on this turtle
and this was able to track it.
So, let's see.
Followed, not hunted.
He's not trying to kill the turtles,
or anything.
It's not like he's
traveling over the turtle,
and it's not like he's...
He's not searching for the turtle.
He actually knows where the turtle is
because he has a satellite tag on it.
So he followed the turtle.
Well, they seem to validate each other.
They were both working on magnetic fields
and how magnetic fields
can be used by turtles to navigate.
No, that's not the case.
So, this one seems interesting.
I'm actually gonna go back to the passage
to make sure that it was
Putman building on Lohmann
versus Lohmann building on Putman.
This could be interesting as well.
It wasn't like, I mean,
the passage said that Putman's research
was wrong,
so we can rule these two out,
but let's revisit the
passage a little bit,
just so that we can
make sure we understand
the work.
So, they told us,
how did she, Adelita,
steer across two oceans
to find her destination?
It says Putnam has the answer.
So Ken Lohmann is his advisor.
He's his mentor.
So, I'm starting to feel
that he probably built on
the work of Ken Lohmann,
'cause Lohmann has been
studying the magnetic abilities
of loggerheads for over 20 years!
So, Putman is a junior researcher,
so I think
he's building on the work.
He's building on the work of Lohmann.
He works in Lohmann's lab.
Lohmann's been doing this for 20 years.
So, let's see where they do that.
Line 49.
Reed.
So, let's see.
All right,
so they're giving these other examples
to say, "Hey, like, turtles
are not the only ones
"that have this mysterious ability."
No, that's not what they're trying to do.
Yeah, this is feeling pretty good.
No, they're not saying most animals,
they're just saying there
are some other animal species
that have this amazing ability,
so they're not saying that most species.
Let me just cross it out like this.
No, they're not saying that the
reed warbler or the sparrow,
because they can travel long distance,
are able to do this or
that or find more food.
They're just saying, "Hey,
turtles are not the only one.
"There's other species that also
can do this."
So, I'll cross that out.
And I'd go with B.